Brody are you team jelly or whole Berry  my family always have the jelly well  that's too bad because my family always  did whole Berry and I'm going to show  you how  you have to show Aunt Janet who the  sauce boss really is all right you know  the drill  so satisfying I love adding chopped  Apple to Cranberry sauce even if you're  going to make a homemade because  cranberries are so tart there's a lot of  added sugar here and the Apple helps to  stretch out that Sugar by adding lots of  natural sweetness not to mention I think  it gives it a nice texture plus it adds  lots of fiber as well  I'm also going to add a little orange  zest here to bump up the cranberry  flavor  just add some apple and fastest way to  make a can of cranberries look homemade